i know you're selected with projects
what was it about this project that said
um i really want to do this
i never
really played somebody like this i mean
i guess you could
point to certain
moments in certain movies
i haven't really thought about this but
you probably
maybe you could one could look at and go
well you're kind of like that him there
in this movie
maybe but
in total i've never really played this
you know uh
and i and i thought i thought for a
movie in this genre
uh it was really well written and
in some scenes
kind of funny
uh
and so so why not it was the right time
the deal was good you know it's
international
uh you know it's a real surreal
international movie and backdrop and
you know it was a challenge to see if i
could pull it off man i have so many
questions i really wanted to ask you
though i love the scene in the
restaurant with you and maggie playing
off each other the dialogue the way it's
filmed uh can you sort of talk about
filming that scene
yeah it was just fun and honestly it
kind of went like that between she and i
she was right on her game and
i don't i'm not sure but i don't think
she gets to
play that
often enough you know she plays the
other parts
that we see in her do in the movie but
uh and so she made it easy and martin
was really good about how he wanted to
shoot it and uh
it's uh
you know the guy did casino royale so
you
you know
he had that big movie
look to it and uh it was pretty easy and
it kind of the kind of weak
there weren't that many takes really uh
um
it was it was fun you know smart
dialogue is always always fun and and i
think unexpected coming from
these two characters in movies like this